this week we commemorate the
extraordinary courage and sacrifice of
those who gave their lives for our
Liberty on d-day seventy-five years ago
as leaders prepare to gather here from
across the world it is fitting that we
begin with the celebration of the
special relationship between the United
Kingdom and the United States enduring
partners who stood side-by-side on that
historic day and every day since four
generations at the heart of the
transatlantic alliance has been our
shared democratic values our common
interests and our commitment to justice
it is that unity of purpose that will
preserve the deep-rooted ties between
our people and underpin our nation's
security and prosperity for the next 75
years and beyond so I am very pleased to
welcome the President of the United
States of America on this state visit to
the United Kingdom for the past
two-and-a-half years the president and I
have had the duty and privilege of being
the latest guardians of this precious
and profound friendship between our
countries as with our predecessors when
we have faced threats to the security of
our citizens and our allies we have
stood together and acted together when
Russia used a deadly nerve agent on the
streets of our country alongside the
UK's expulsion z' the president expelled
60 Russian intelligence officers the
largest contribution towards an
unprecedented global response and in
Syria when innocent men women and
children were victims of a barbaric
chemical weapons attack Britain and
America along with France carried out
targeted strikes against the regime
since we spoke about NATO during my
first visit to the White House we have
maintained our support for this crucial
alliance thanks in part your clear
message on burden-sharing Donald we have
seen members pledged another 100 billion
dollars increasing their contributions
to our shared security and I'm pleased
to announce that neh
we'll soon be able to call on the UK's
queen elizabeth-class aircraft carriers
and f-35 fighter jets to help tackle
threats around the world today we've
discussed again the new and evolving
challenges to our security our values
and our way of life we share the same
view about their origin and our
objectives in meeting them but like
prime ministers and presidents before us
and no doubt those that will come after
we can also differ sometimes on how to
confront the challenges we face I've
always talked openly with you Donald
when we have taken a different approach
and you've done the same with me I've
always believed that cooperation and
compromise are the basis of strong
alliances and nowhere is this more true
than in the special relationship today
we've discussed again the importance of
our two nations working together to
address Iran's destabilizing activity in
the region and to in short Iran cannot
acquire a nuclear weapon although we
differ on the means of achieving that as
I've said before the UK continues to
stand by the nuclear deal it is clear
that we both want to reach the same goal
it is important that Iran meets its
obligations and we do everything to
avoid escalation which is in no one's
interest recognizing our nations are
safer and more prosperous when we work
together on the biggest challenges of
our time I also set out the UK's
approach to tackling climate change and
our continued support for the Paris
agreement and we also spoke about China
recognizing its economic significance
and that we cannot ignore action that
threatens our shared interests or values
as we've deepened our cooperation on
security including our joint military
operations and our unparalleled
Intelligence Sharing so our economies to
our ever more tightly bound together
every morning 1 million Americans get up
and go to work for British companies in
America and 1 million Britons do the
same for American companies here our
trading relationship is worth over 190
billion pounds a year and we're the
largest investors in each other's
economies with mutual investments valued
at as much as one trillion dollars mr.
president you and I agreed the first
time we met that we should aim for an
ambitious free-trade
agreement when the UK leaves the EU and
from our positive discussions today I
know that we both remain committed to
this I'm also sure that our economic
relationship will only grow broader and
deeper building on the conversations we
had and the ideas we heard from UK and
US businesses when we met them earlier
today tomorrow we will sit down in
Portsmouth with our fellow leaders to
Rio for but reaffirm the enduring
importance of the Western alliance and
the shared values that underpin it and
as we look to the future in the years
and in the generations ahead we will
continue to work together to preserve
the alliance that is the bedrock of our
shared prosperity and security just as
it was on the beaches of Normandy 75
years ago mr. president
well Thank You Prime Minister may Lonnie
and I are honored to return to London as
our nation's commemorate the 75th
anniversary of d-day in World War two we
want to thank her Majesty the Queen who
I had a lovely dinner with the last
night a fantastic person fantastic woman
for so graciously inviting us to this
state visit it was very very special our
thanks as well to Prime Minister and mr.
May for the warm welcome
they've given the first lady and me as
we remember the heroes who laid down
their lives to rescue civilization
itself on June 6th 1944 tens of
thousands of young warriors left the
shores by the sea and air
to begin the invasion of Normandy and
the liberation of Europe and the brutal
Nazi occupation it was a liberation like
few people have seen before
among them were more than 130,000
American and British brothers in arms
through their valor and sacrifice they
secured our homelands and save freedom
for the world tomorrow Prime Minister
may and I will attend a commemoration
ceremony in Portsmouth one of the key
embarked Asian points for the invasion
more than one and a half million
American servicemembers was stationed
right here in England in advance of the
landings that summer the bonds of
friendship forged here and sealed in
blood on those hallowed beaches will
endure forever our special relationship
is grounded in common history values
customs culture language and laws our
people believe in freedom and
independence as a sacred birthright and
cherished inheritance worth defending at
any cost
as the Prime Minister and I discussed in
our meetings today and yesterday the
United States and the United Kingdom
share many goals and priorities around
the world
I want to thank the people of the United
Kingdom for their service and
partnership in our campaign to defeat
Isis as we announced a few months ago
Isis's territorial Caliphate in Syria in
Iraq has been completely obliterated
defeated the United Kingdom is also a
key partner in NATO the Prime Minister
and I agree that our NATO allies must
increase their defence spending we both
been working very hard toward that end
and we are very current and some of them
are not we can't allow that to happen
but I appreciate everything you've done
in that regard we expect a growing
number of nations to meet the minimum 2
percent of GDP requirement to address
today's challenges all members of the
Alliance must fulfill their obligations
they have no choice they must fulfill
their obligation among the pressing
threats facing our nations is the
development and spread of nuclear
weapons
perhaps that's our greatest threat the
United States and the United Kingdom are
determined to ensure that Iran never
develops nuclear weapons and stop
supporting and engaging in terrorism and
I believe that will happen in protecting
our nation's we also know that the
border security is national security
today the Prime Minister and I discussed
our thriving economic relationship both
countries are doing very well and
participated in a roundtable with
industry and business leaders I can say
probably the biggest business leaders
anywhere in the world our nations have
more than 1 trillion dollars invested in
each other's economics the United
Kingdom is America's largest foreign
investor in our largest European export
market that's a lot of importance as the
UK makes preparations to exit the
European Union the United States is
committed to a phenomenal trade deal
between the u.s. and the UK there is
tremendous potential in that trade deal
I say probably two and even three times
of what we're doing right now tremendous
potential 75 years ago this Thursday
courageous Americans and British
Patriots set out from this island toward
history's most important battle they
stormed forward out of ships and
airplanes risking everything to defend
our people and to ensure that the United
States and Britain would forever remain
sovereign and forever remain free
following this press conference Prime
Minister may mr. May the first lady my
family and I will visit the legendary
Churchill war rooms beneath the streets
of London I look forward to that in his
famous speech on this day in June 1940
Prime Minister Churchill urge his
countrymen to defend our island whatever
the cost may be as we mark this solemn
anniversary of d-day we remember that
the defense of our nations does not
begin on the battlefield
but within the heart of every Patriot
today let us renew our pledge engraved
at the American Cemetery in Normandy and
inscribed by President Dwight Eisenhower
in st. Paul's Cathedral right here in
London that the cause for which they
died shall live Prime Minister may it's
been a true honor I have greatly enjoyed
working with you you are a tremendous
professional and a person that loves
your country dearly thank you very much
really an honor thank you for the
invitation to memorialize our fallen
heroes and for your partnership in
protecting and advancing the
extraordinary alliance between the
American and the British people it's the
greatest alliance the world has ever
known
Thank You Prime Minister thank you thank
you
thank you now we're going to take two
questions from the UK media and two
questions from the American media I'll
start with Beth Rigby thank you Thank
You Prime Minister president Trump Beth
Rigby from Sky News for You president
Trump as you hold talks with the current
Prime Minister the leader of Her
Majesty's opposition has been addressed
in a protest rally against your visit in
Trafalgar Square
he says he's disappointed you attacked
the London mayor and he criticized your
record on refugees what do you have to
say to him and is this man someone you
could do a trade deal with and to you
prime minister do you think that Sadiq
Khan is a stone-cold loser
thank you you're talking about the Mayor
of London is that who you said yes well
I think he's been a not very good mayor
from what I understand he's done a poor
job crime is up a lot of problems and I
don't think he should be criticizing a
representative of the United States that
can do so much good for the United
Kingdom we talked about it before he
should be positive not negative he's a
negative force not a positive force and
if you look at what he said he hurts the
people of this great country and I think
he should actually focus on his job it'd
be a lot better if he did that he could
straighten out some of the problems that
he has and probably some of the problems
that he's caused thank you good night
yes you wanted to meet with me and I
told him no yes well I don't know Jeremy
Corbyn never met him never spoke to him
he wanted to meet today or tomorrow and
I I decided that I would not do that I
think that he is from where I come from
somewhat of a negative force I think
that the people should look to do things
correctly as opposed to criticize I
really don't like critics as much as I
like and respect people that get things
done so I've decided not to meet as far
as the protests I have to tell you
because I commented on it yesterday
we left the prime minister the Queen the
royal family there were thousands of
people on the streets cheering and even
coming over today there were thousands
of people cheering and then I heard that
there were protests I said where are the
protests I don't see any protests I did
see a small protest today when I came
very small so a lot of it is fake news I
hate to say but you saw the the people
waving the American flag waving your
flag it was tremendous spirit and love
there was great love it was an alliance
and I didn't see the protesters or till
just a little while ago and it was a
very very small group of people put in
for political reasons so it was fake
news thank you and I would say to both
the mayor of London and to Jeremy Corbyn
the discussions that we have had today
are about the future of this most
important relationship between the u.s.
and the UK as the president described it
the greatest alliance the world has seen
it is this deep special relationship and
partnership between the United States in
the United Kingdom that ensures our
safety and security and the safety and
security of others around the world -
and it is this relationship that helps
to ensure there are jobs that employ
people here in the UK and in the United
States that underpins our prosperity and
our future that is a relationship we
should cherish it is a relationship we
should build on it is a relationship we
should be proud of this big and this
really is a very big import
and Alliance and I think people should
act positively toward it because it
means so much for both countries means
so much and it's been so good Steve
Holland yes go ahead Steve
Thank You mr. prank you is that bond
there what is your current view on
brexit sir she had Britain leave the
European Union if there is no agreement
by October 31st and for the Prime
Minister what would be the ramifications
for the UK if there is not a deal well I
don't like to take positions in things
that I'm not you know really I
understand the issue very well I really
predicted what was going to happen some
of you remember that prediction it was a
strong prediction made at a certain
location on a development we were
opening the day before it happened and I
thought it was going to happen because
of immigration more than anything else
but probably it happens for a lot of
reasons but I would say yeah I would
think that it will happen and it
probably should happen this is a great
great country and it wants its own
identity it wants to have its own
borders it wants to run its own affairs
is a very very special place and I think
it deserves a special place and I
thought maybe for that reason and for
others but that reason it was going to
happen yeah I think it will happen and I
believe the Prime Minister's brought it
to a very good point where something
will take place in the not-too-distant
future I think she's done a very good
job I believe it would be good for the
country yes and from my point of view I
believe it is important for us to
deliver brexit we gave that choice to
the British people Parliament
overwhelmingly gave the choice to the
British people we should now deliver on
that choice I continue to believe that
actually it's in the best interests of
the UK to leave the European Union in an
orderly way with a deal I think we have
a good deal sadly the Labour Party and
other MPs have so far stopped us from
delivering a brexit in that deal but we
will but obviously this is an issue that
is going to continue here in the UK I
think the important thing is we deliver
brexit and once we're out of the
European Union we will be able to do
what we've been talking about today and
develop not just that free trade
agreement but a broader
partnership into the future matter mr.
president are you prepared to impose
limits on intelligence sharing with
Britain if they do not put in place some
restrictions on Huawei no because we're
gonna have absolutely an agreement on
Huawei and everything else we have an
incredible intelligence relationship and
we will be able to work out any
differences I think we're not gonna have
we did discuss it I see absolutely no
limitations we've never had limitations
this is a truly great ally and partner
and we'll have no problem with that okay
Francis mr. president Francis Daley from
The Times do you agree with your
ambassador that the entire economy needs
to be on the table in a future trade
talk a trade deal including the MHS and
Prime Minister EU tempted to take the
Prime Minister president of the world
and stick around for a bit until a trade
deal is done I think we're going to have
a great trade deal yes I think we're
going to have a great and very
comprehensive trade deal
I can't hear look I think everything
with the trade deal is on the table when
you when you're dealing and trade
everything's on the table so NHS or
anything else or a lot a lot more than
that but everything will be on the table
absolutely okay but the point about
making trade deals is of course that
both sides negotiate and come to an
agreement about what should or should
not be in that trade deal for the for
the future and as regards your second
question Frances nice try
but but no look I'm a woman of my word
John please mr. president Thank You mr.
president
domestically in recent days Mexico has
stepped up apprehensions and
deportations of Central American
migrants it's good this could possibly
be in in response to your threat of
tariffs has Mexico and possibly B has it
has Mexico done enough to avoid tariffs
which will be imposed in some six days
from now we haven't started yet and and
but the threat is out there yeah the
threat is out there but we haven't
really started yet no this will take
effect next week and what 5% and what do
you think of Republicans who say that
they may take action to block you
imposing those - I don't think they will
do that I think if they did it's foolish
there's nothing more important than
borders I've had tremendous Republican
support I have a ninety percent ninety
four percent approval rating as of this
morning in the Republican Party that's
an all-time record can you believe that
isn't that something I love records but
we have a 94 percent approval rating in
the Republican Party I want to see
security at our border I'm going to see
great trade I'm going to see a lot of
things happening and that is happening
and as you know Mexico call they want to
meet they're going to meet on Wednesday
secretary Pompeo is going to be at the
meeting along with a few others that are
very good at this and we are going to
see if we can do something but I think
it's more likely that the tariffs go on
and we'll probably be talking during the
time that the tariffs are on and they're
going to be paid and if they don't step
and give us security for our nation look
millions of people are flowing through
Mexico that's unacceptable millions and
millions of people are coming right
through Mexico it's a 2,000 mile journey
and they're coming up to our border and
our Border Patrol which is incredible
they're apprehending them but our laws
are bad because the Democrats don't want
to pass laws that could be passed in 15
minutes that could be passed quickly in
one day it could change but even beyond
the laws Mexico shouldn't allow millions
of people to try and enter our country
and they could stop it very quickly and
I think they will and if they won't
we're gonna put tariffs on and every
month those tariffs go from 5 percent to
10 percent to 15 percent to 20 and then
to 25 percent and what will happen then
is all of those companies that have left
our country and gone to Mexico are going
to be coming back to us and that's okay
that's okay but I think Mexico will step
up and do what they should have been
done and I don't want to hear that
Mexico is run by the cartels and the
drug lords and the Coyotes I don't want
to hear about that a lot of people are
saying that Mexico has something to
prove but I don't want to hear that
they're run by the cartels you
understand you report on it all the time
a lot of people do I would be a terrible
thing Mexico should step up and stop
this onslaught this invasion into our
country John mr. mayor you tried three
times to get a deal on brexit at this
point do you believe that a deal on
brexit is possible or is this a Gordian
knot president Trump says that you
didn't take his advice in terms of
negotiation should you have would that
have made a difference in President
Trump if I could ask a follow-up you had
a conversation with Boris Johnson could
we ask what you spoke about and will you
meet with Michael Gove today well first
of all on the first issues I said in
answer to an earlier question I still
believe I personally believe that it is
in the best interest of the UK to leave
the European Union with a deal I believe
there is a good deal on the on the table
obviously it will be for whoever
succeeds me as
Minister to take this issue forward what
is paramount I believe is delivering on
brexit for the for the British people
and I seem to remember the the president
suggested that I sued the European Union
which we didn't do we went into
negotiations and we came out with a good
deal that's not such as I would have
sued but that's okay I would have sued
and settled maybe but you never know
she's probably a better negotiator than
I am Jeremy but you know what she has
got it in a sense John that deal is teed
up I think that these really teed up I
think they have to do something and
perhaps you won't be given the credit
that you deserve if they do something
but I think you deserve a lot of credit
I really do I think you deserve a lot of
credit okay yes John so I know Boris I
like him I've liked him for a long time
he's I think he'd do a very good job
I know Jeremy I think he'd do a very
good job I don't know Michael but would
he do a good job Jeremy time
okay good thank you very much everybody
thank you thank you very much